on est délivré du cycle de réincarnations.
C'est une idée vraiment puissante
d'être libéré de la vie telle que nous la connaissons.
C'est ce qui attire ces millions de pèlerins.
Et une mégapole entière est construite pour les héberger.
Sept millions de personnes y vivent pendant les 55 jours
et 100 autres millions la visitent.
Voici des photos du même endroit,
pris tout au long des 10 semaines
que met la ville pour sortir de terre.
Après la mousson,
quand les eaux des deux fleuves commencent à se retirer
et que les bancs de sable se dévoilent,
cet endroit devient l'emplacement de la ville.
Et le 15 janvier,
du 15 octobre au 15 janvier,
une ville entière émerge en quelques semaines.
Une ville qui héberge sept millions de personnes.
Ce qui est fascinant, c'est que cette ville
a toutes les caractéristiques d'une véritable mégapole :
on a recours à un tracé pour établir la ville.
Le système urbain forme une grille
et chaque rue de cette ville
traverse le fleuve sur un pont flottant.
Il est incroyablement résilient
car, en cas d'averse imprévue pour la saison ou si le fleuve change son cours,
le système urbain reste intact,
la ville s'ajuste à ce terrain potentiellement mouvant.
Elle en reproduit aussi toutes les infrastructures physiques et sociales.
L'eau courante, la gestion des eaux usées, l'électricité,
1 400 caméras de vidéosurveillance assurent la sécurité
et un commissariat entier est installé.
Mais aussi des infrastructures sociales,
des cliniques, des hôpitaux,
toutes sortes de services communautaires,
qui permettent un fonctionnement comme dans n'importe quelle mégapole.
10 500 balayeurs sont employés par la ville.
Il y a un système de gouvernance, le Mela Adhikari
appelé aussi préfet du pèlerinage,
qui s'assure que les terrains soient alloués –
il y a des systèmes pour tout ça,
que l'organisation de la mobilité urbaine fonctionne bien.
C'était la plus propre et la plus efficace des villes indiennes
où j'ai vécu.
(Rires)
Et voici à quoi elle ressemble en comparaison à Manhattan,
30 kilomètres carrés,
c'est la taille de la ville.
Et ce n'est ni une ville sans plan ni une ville champignon.
C'est une ville avec un plan directeur, une initiative publique
que l'administration met en place.
Dans le monde actuel néolibéral et capitaliste,
où l’État a renoncé lui-même à la responsabilité
de réaliser et concevoir les villes,
c'est une chose incroyable.
C'est une ville mûrement réfléchie, voulue et planifiée.
Et c'est une ville avec une très faible empreinte sur le sol.
Elle se trouve sur les rives de ces deux fleuves.
Et elle laisse très peu de traces.
Il n'y pas de fondations,
La construction de la ville entière est réalisée sur des tissus.
Ce qui est également incroyable,
c'est qu'on utilise cinq matériaux pour construire cet aménagement
qui héberge sept millions de personnes :
du bambou de 2,5 mètres de haut, de la ficelle ou de la corde,
des clous ou des vis et une matière pour couvrir,
du métal ondulé, du tissu ou du plastique.
Ces matériaux s'assemblent et se combinent.
C'est comme un kit,
utilisé depuis la petite tente,
qui peut héberger cinq-six personnes ou une famille,
jusqu'aux temples pouvant accueillir 500, parfois 1 000 personnes.
Ce kit, cette idée de la ville,
lui permet d'être démontée.
Et ainsi, à la fin du pèlerinage, en une semaine,
la ville entière est démontée.
Voici à nouveau des images du même endroit.
Le terrain est rendu au fleuve,
et, avec la mousson, ses eaux s'y déverseront à nouveau.
Et c'est cette conception modulaire, ce kit,
qui permet un tel démontage
et la reconversion de tous ces matériaux.
Les poteaux électriques vont dans les petits villages de l'arrière-pays,
les ponts flottants sont utilisés dans les bourgs
et tous les matériaux sont reconvertis.
Fascinant et incroyable.
Qu'on adhère au non aux croyances hindoues,
c'est un exemple remarquable,
qui mérite réflexion.
Les humains y mettent énormément d'énergie et d'imagination,
en sachant que la ville va revenir à la terre,
elle va être démontée,
elle va disparaître,
c'est la mégapole éphémère.
Et elle a des leçons essentielles à nous apprendre.
Des leçons sur la façon d'effleurer le sol,
sur la réversibilité,
sur le démontage.
Absolument incroyable.
Nous les humains, sommes obsédés par la permanence.
Nous résistons au changement.
C'est un instinct que nous avons tous.
Nous y résistons malgré le fait
que le changement est peut-être la seule constante dans notre vie.
Tout a une date d'expiration,
y compris le Vaisseau Terre, notre planète.
Que pouvons-nous apprendre de toutes ces sortes d'aménagements ?
Le Burning Man est bien sûr plus petit,
mais réversible.
Ou les milliers de marchés de rue,
qui surgissent dans le monde entier
en Asie, en Amérique Latine, en Afrique, comme celui-ci au Mexique
où les places de parking sont animées les week-ends par près de 50 000 vendeurs,
mais de façon temporaire.
Le marché de producteurs en Amérique :
c'est un phénomène étonnant, qui crée de nouvelles alchimies.
Il étend la marge de l'espace
qui n'est pas utilisé à 100%, comme les places de parking par exemple.
Dans ma propre ville de Bombay,
où j'exerce mon métier d'architecte et d'urbaniste,
je le vois dans le paysage urbain tous les jours.
J'appelle cela la ville cinétique.
Elle se contracte comme un organisme vivant, elle n'est pas statique.
Elle change tous les jours,
avec parfois des cycles prévisibles.
Près de six millions de personnes
vivent dans ces sortes d'aménagements temporaires.
Comme – malheureusement, comme les camps de réfugiés,
les bidonvilles de Bombay, les favelas d'Amérique Latine.
Le temporaire y devient la nouvelle permanence.
L'urbanisme n'y est pas une question de grande vision,
mais de grande adaptation.
Dans la rue de Bombay, pendant le festival de Ganesh,
une transformation se produit.
Un édifice public est créé pour 10 jours.
Des films de Bollywood sont projetés,
des milliers de gens se rassemblent pour dîner et faire la fête.
Il est construit avec du papier mâché et du plâtre.
Conçu pour être démonté,
dix jours plus tard, il disparaît
et la rue redevient anonyme.
Ou les merveilleuses esplanades que nous appelons « maidans ».
Nous les utilisons pour ce jeu indien extraordinairement nuancé,
compliqué et fascinant, appelé le cricket,
que les Anglais ont inventé, je crois.
(Rires)
Et le soir,
un mariage enveloppe le terrain de cricket –
remarquez qu'il n'est pas touché, c'est un espace sacré.
(Rires)
Mais ici, les membres du club et la fête du mariage
dînent ensemble dans la cuisine commune.
Et à minuit, tout est démonté
et l'espace est rendu au public.
L'urbanisme est ici un état élastique.
Et donc, si nous réfléchissons à ces questions,
je pense que beaucoup de choses viennent à l'esprit.
Voici une question importante :
sommes-nous vraiment, dans nos villes,
dans notre façon de voir l'urbanisme,
en train de trouver des solutions permanentes à des problèmes temporaires ?
Bloquons-nous des ressources dans des modèles
dont nous ne savons même pas s'ils seront pertinents dans dix ans ?
Je pense que cela devient
une question intéressante découlant de nos recherches.
Regardez les centres commerciaux abandonnés d'Amérique du Nord,
dans les banlieues.
Les experts du commerce de détail pensent que dans les dix prochaines années,
sur les 2 000 centres commerciaux en activité aujourd'hui,
50% seront abandonnés.
Une quantité énorme de matériaux, retenant des ressources,
qui ne sera bientôt plus pertinente.
Ou les stades olympiques.
Partout dans le monde, les villes en construisent
avec des ressources considérables malgré beaucoup de contestations,
mais quand les Jeux sont terminés,
ils ne peuvent souvent pas être absorbés par la ville.
Ne pourrait-on pas construire des structures nomades, démontables –
nous avons la technologie pour ça,
puis les offrir aux plus petites villes dans le monde ou dans ces pays,
ou les stocker et les réutiliser pour les prochains Jeux Olympiques ?
Une utilisation considérable et inefficace de ressources.
Comme un cirque.
On pourrait imaginer ça comme un cirque,
cette merveilleuse institution qui campait dans les villes
et a établi cette charmante forme de dialogue visuel avec la ville statique.
Et à l'intérieur, l'émerveillement.
Les enfants de toutes origines deviennent conscients les uns des autres,
des gens différents se rencontrent,
les groupes sociaux, les cultures, les nationalités
sont tous réunis dans l'émerveillement de la piste, des animaux et des artistes.
De nouvelles alchimies se créent quand les gens en prennent conscience
et se répètent dans la prochaine ville.
Ou les flux naturels, le changement climatique,
comment y faire face ? Comment pouvons-nous mieux nous y adapter ?
Pouvons-nous créer des systèmes urbains plus souples ?
Ou allons-nous défier la nature continuellement
avec des infrastructures lourdes,
ce que nous faisons déjà, sans succès ?
Je ne dis pas
que nous devons faire de nos villes des cirques,
je ne dis pas que les villes doivent être entièrement temporaires.
Je lance seulement un appel
en faveur d'un changement de notre façon d'imaginer les villes,
où nous devons donner plus de place
aux usages temporaires.
Là où nous devons utiliser nos ressources efficacement
afin de retarder la date d'expiration de notre planète.
Nous devons changer la façon de concevoir la planification urbaine
en pensant éphémère, réversible
et démontable.
Et cela peut avoir énormément
d'effets sur notre vie.
Je repense souvent à la Kumba Mela
que j'ai visitée avec mes étudiants pour l'étudier,
au moment où la ville avait été démontée.
Une semaine après la fin du festival.
Il n'y avait aucune trace.
Le sol attendait d'être recouvert par les eaux,
d'être englouti.
Et je suis allé remercier une grande prêtresse
qui m'avait aidé, moi et mes étudiants, dans nos recherches
et nous avait facilité la tâche pendant tout ce projet.
Je suis allé la voir avec grand enthousiasme
pour lui dire combien nous avions appris
des infrastructures, de la ville, de l'efficacité de la ville,
de l'architecture, des cinq matériaux qui ont façonné la ville.
Elle avait l'air vraiment amusée, elle souriait.
En tout cas, elle s'est penchée en avant
et a posé sa main sur ma tête pour me bénir.
Elle a chuchoté à mon oreille :
« Estimez-vous bénis que la mère Gange
vous ait tous permis de vous asseoir sur ses genoux pendant quelques jours. »
J'y ai souvent réfléchi,
et naturellement j'ai compris ce qu'elle voulait dire.
Les villes, les gens, l'architecture vont et viennent,
mais notre planète est là pour un moment.
Effleurons le sol, laissons une empreinte minimale.
A mon avis, c'est un précepte important pour nous, citoyens et architectes.
Je pense que c'est cette rencontre
qui m'a convaincu que l'éphémère est plus fort que la permanence,
plus fort que nous tous.
Merci de votre écoute.
(Applaudissements)